[Music]
well guess all I can do is hope this
video adds to your pile of good things
[Applause]
[Music]
Vincent and the doctor this is one that
has been very steadily going up in my
estimation since I first saw it I've
never disliked it but when I first saw
it I didn't completely get it
and I think a lot of that just gets
chalked up to youth in an experience I
was I was you know still in my 20s when
I saw this the first time and I didn't
yet have the life experience to fully
appreciate what was doing and how well
it did it I put too much stock into the
trappings and the monster which isn't
really what it's about except it is but
the monster isn't there to function as a
standard Doctor Who monster it's there
for other purposes which is something
that I appreciate a lot more now and
it's this episode is kind of a singular
piece of work to be completely honest
and the very nature of honestly a lot of
the historical Doctor Who episodes and
in general like John I usually don't
like them they're very formulaic because
they're usually just an excuse to have
some actor who's a ringer for some
famous historical figure come in and you
know give what ranges from a good
performance to a hammy one depending on
who they're portraying and you drop in a
random sci-fi monster and off we go and
that's kind of the template that keeps
getting used and I find it
dull and not particularly interesting
and often really contrived but this time
first of all choosing to have it be
Vincent van Gogh as someone who was not
important during his own life because
every other historical figure that
modern era doctor who has chosen to
portray were people who had at least
some understanding of their importance
maybe not the full scope of it you know
certainly with Agatha Christie she
didn't think her stories would continue
but she was a published author
obviously Churchill had plenty of ego
Dickens was well established Queen
Victoria yeah so you're dealing with you
know you know Shakespeare he was well
established in his career by the time
they did a story with him these are
people who maybe don't have a
appreciation of how big a place they
have in history but they know they have
value in the now and vinson didn't have
that and it was a tricky thing to choose
to portray him because he's easily the
most immediately complicated character
that the show's tried to tackle there
isn't a clean obvious way to depict him
because it was a very complicated person
with a lot going on that you know
there's been a lot of post-mortem
psychological diagnosis done on this van
Gogh over the years but ultimately we
don't know it was wrong we know that he
was very unstable and that he
self-medicate with alcohol but that's
about it
and that's a complicated and fairly
heavy character for someone like Doctor
Who to tackle and for it to tackle it as
well as it does is incredibly impressive
Tony Koran who's an actor who I already
knew and already liked I remember first
taking note of him in the 13th warrior
which is actually a film like I quite
enjoy it always bugs me when I get
reminded that it's one of the biggest
box-office bombs of all time I actually
really liked that movie but anyway I I
kind of knew who he was and I'd seen him
in one or two other things as well but
he's terrific cuz it's really hard to
play a character who can turn on a dime
and have that feel consistent because it
is inherently inconsistent behavior so
to try and have that not feel like bad
characterization but instead be all
these very contradictory facets of one
consistent person that's a hard thing to
pull off and he does it really really
well and all some of his best moments
are ones where he has no dialogue at all
just looks he see the weight of things
on him and I especially you know at the
end and the gallery but even before that
when when the doctor mentions that once
they take care of the monster they'll be
out of his hair out of his life and when
he realizes that these people who have
swept into his life and are being kind
to him we're going to leave the same way
that in his mind everyone leaves
everyone always leaves and it feeds into
his it's just something the doctor says
but it feeds into Vincent's fears and
his anxiety and his depression and his
demons of course you'll leave everyone
leaves get out
and all of that rings very very true and
I think a big part of why I didn't
appreciate this episode as much when it
first aired is because I I'm I'm very
fortunate I do not suffer from
depression I never have but I've had
enough life experience especially over
the last decade or so with people
numerous people some I've known for a
while some of only got to know more
recently but a lot of people who are
important in my life suffer from some
form of depression and even though it's
never been my own personal experience
I've been close enough to it to be able
to recognize a lot of what is being
shown and reflected in this episode
because that's daddy's what this episode
is and it's what I failed to fully
appreciate the very first time I saw it
this is not an episode about a monster
not an alien monster it's an episode
about a personal monster it's not even
really an episode about Vincent van Gogh
it's an episode about depression and it
is an incredibly knowledgeable and well
understood episode about depression a
written by Richard Curtis of all people
probably best known as the writer and
director of Love Actually of all things
and writer of films like Four Weddings
and a funeral the understanding at play
of how depression eats at not only the
people who suffer from it but the people
around them who care about them and
that's what I think really kind of puts
this episode up above simply being a
very good depiction of depression
acknowledging that no matter what they
did no matter what they said Finn simple
is always going to die he was always
going to kill himself and it was always
gonna do it at the time he's always done
it they can give him an amazing day they
can show him the impact that he will
leave on the world but that doesn't fix
him and it's very important between the
doctor and Amy to have Amy have that
moment of well it didn't matter because
he died anyway and for the doctor to
tell her no it did still matter cuz we
added to his pile of good things and
this notion of a life being a pile of
good things and bad things and the good
things don't erase the bad things but
the bad things also don't negate what
was brought about by the good things and
some people regardless of whether or not
they as far as experiences go have had
more bad things than good things the way
that their brain filters things some
people just will always put more weight
in the bad things and that's what
Vincent's mind did and the doctor knew
you could see it when they go back into
the gallery and Amy's expecting to see
new paints and paintings and the doctor
tries to prep her that's probably not
gonna be the case but that makes the
effort that he did cuz let me think
about what he did he took a historical
figure far into the future and showed
him
his impact and his legacy the doctor
doesn't do that
he'll hint with various historical
figures as to their importance but he
doesn't tell them I mean the last time
he did that I mean it was a
fictionalized historical figure but from
his perspective it's a historical figure
that was with Adelaide Brooke waters of
Mars and it was a horrible outcome so
for him to do that and I think in my
reading knowing it is not going to
change how his life ends but also
knowing that for right now in this
moment he can give him something that no
one else can and he can give him a good
thing and for this moment
Vincent can revel and pay than that good
moment it won't last but that doesn't
mean it's devoid of value the
understanding this episode displays of
depression and its impact on those who
suffer from it and those who care about
people who suffer from it and
emphasizing the value of these
connections in these relationships and
pointing out that it doesn't matter if
this ends badly because it can that
doesn't make it not worth it there's so
much compassion and understanding in
this episode and the monster
Vincente battling a monster that no one
else can see all they can see is him
acting mad as he tries to wrestle with
this thing
if you're really dumb for not getting
that when I first saw it but I'm very
glad I get it now and everyone else is
great in it too Matt Smith is great
Karen Gillan's great Bill Nye he's great
and it was kind of fun for me to see him
in this because he was he was who I was
secretly hoping would be cast as the
doctor coming off of Tennant
so I did like seeing him you know in the
room with Smith but this is this is Tony
quran's episode and his performances
Vincent is astounding and it's
wonderfully wonderfully realized that is
a beautiful piece that works is a
self-contained treatise on depression
and a really good one Vincent and the
doctor have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
and let's talk about it there is a bunch
of stuff to do as well if you enjoyed
this video you can support me on patreon
and help things get bigger and better
help me keep the lights on there is the
light to subscribe both those things are
worth hitting I think I've been told
here all the cool kids are doing it plus
there's other links down there as well
that you can click on but also you don't
have to do if you think it'll add to
your pile of good things I hope you will
but at the end of the day you're the
council I'm just running the meanings
until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]